[Music]
let's go out to Tallahassee Florida and
talk to Mary Mary why what's up Mary oh
not much not
much are you doing all
right yeah I'm doing okay I reckon very
cool so what's
up uh so I've been dating a guy almost
six years and um since his children were
12 and he has not let me be a part of
his children's lives he would not let me
be around them and we live separately
and he's letting me move in the day
after they graduate saying that if his
children want to be a part of my life
they can make that decision as adults um
and I'm just want to know is that normal
in some people's lives where they don't
want other mother figures to come into
their children's lives and and you know
being an in infuence in any
way uh this whole thing sounds
weird yeah it's it's caused quite a
quite a big issue in our relationship
because when he has his children I can't
see him so they're they're all is he
this sounds like he's got something else
going on no no there's photos of us up
around his home they know about us I
have photos of us together on Facebook
um but when they go to family get
togethers I can't go if his children are
there why have you ever met them I had
to meet them um at a funeral because
someone in his family close passed away
and um of course he didn't want me to go
CU his kids were going to go and I said
I will drive my own car but I'm going
because your family's been part of my
life now for almost six years and they
wanted me to go and they I was invited
by his family and they said we don't
care what he says you are welcome yeah I
would I don't mean to be ugly or
anything but I'd run from this dude as
fast as I can here's why here's why
here's why um he is not living an
integrated
life meaning he is trying to live a life
where he gets to control all the
different segments of his life and by
the way he's done a pretty good job
because you've put up with this crap for
six
years yeah the only way a relationship a
romantic relationship long-term works is
if everybody's all
in now I absolutely believe in slow
playing new Rel relationships when
there's kids from a previous marriage
totally believe in that good good for
him 6 years is
insane it's crazy yes because my
children are around him my and our kids
are the same age that that doesn't mean
anything I don't no but he comes to my
house and eats with my family what's his
reasoning because that's
normal his only reasoning is is that he
the kids can decide when they're grown
but that he will not be and I I'm like
hey you know we're getting close to time
me moving in can I at least come over
some and kind of get to know them
because it's going to be awkward me just
move in and these kids don't know me and
I don't know them and they're going to
still be coming to visit you because
they're still your children why haven't
you married him after more than half a
decade we haven't lived together
so that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard I didn't live with my wife before
we got married most of the people I know
yeah we don't live together because of
the children's situation we live three
miles from each other and it's it has
caused me a lot of Heartache why do you
why have you put up with this for six
years because here's my promise to you
my promise to you he's hiding other
things from you too period end of story
yeah and there's other parts of his life
that you do not have access to because
he says no and you just take it
why I don't know I guess cuz I'm getting
old and kind of feel like you're just
not worth it and you're just going to
cash in on some of like all of a
relation I mean that's just breaks my
heart for you yeah it it hurts just
because I've I've stayed where I'm at as
a single mom paying my own bills and I
haven't moved on with my life because
I've been sitting here waiting on him
all these years I'm G tell you right now
it's not g to happen and by the way if
it
does you're a half a decade afterthought
yeah you know what I mean yeah it's it's
trust me it's cost many many and many
arguments yeah have an argum four years
he wouldn't even answer the phone with
me with the kids around yeah that's
that why did he get
divorced his ex was having an affair
while he was on government Duty
okay yeah I mean do what you're going to
do um I don't I don't really know let me
do this what's your question how can I
help I was just want to know if that was
something that was I've never heard of
it happen I've sat with a lot of people
over the years I've never heard of this
I've never heard of six years I won't
answer the phone when you call if I
happen to be with my kids I don't want
you around you're not allowed to talk to
them or meet them because here's the
thing they do have a choice to make when
they're adults 100% yeah they don't have
a choice when they're kids why because
they're kids right and it's the parents
job to integrate themselves right uh
Carl Rogers one of the great uh
Godfathers of therapy of counseling
calls it congruence Am I who I am
everywhere am I the same person here as
I am over here and some of us have a
work face and we have a relationship
face and we have a a church face and we
have uh going to the store face right
and sometimes you see somebody you're
like dude I don't even know that guy
that is not who or you see somebody at
work and you see them out at you know at
a restaurant and they're just like on
top of the table with two Margarita
pitches and you're like what um that's a
person that's exhausted because they
have to be multiple people throughout
their life yeah and it's very hard to
have a relationship with somebody who
does not is not aiming towards
congruence yeah it's it's been difficult
and I guess the reason I haven't given
up is because I've already put so much
time in in in business we call that a
cost
fallacy I've already put $2 million in
this oh your business is failing well I
know but I've already put 2 million so I
got to put another million in I know but
it's failing it's not working I got to
put another million in right it's just
some cause fallacy Bankers love you he
just says things he says things are
going to be different you know I'm going
to move in and things are going to be
better and this won't be an issue
anymore but I'm like but what about the
other six years that I set a whole loan
on Christmas because my kids were at
their dad's or I sat alone on
Thanksgiving because you I couldn't be
with you and your family cuz you had
your children it's been really
crappy yeah I mean I don't have an
answer for you other than that's gonna
have that's going to have to be
something you all address
together yeah and for him he's not on
the phone so I can't talk to him but for
him if he says I told you at the outset
you can never meet my children until
they're adults period yep end of story
that's what he said yep that's what he
said he said I told you on the first
State then here's the deal all of this
is on you you chose to sit at home on
Christmas I'm not even going to blame
him yeah and that's what he said he said
I told you the first date you stayed and
of course my thinking was oh when he
finds out what kind of a good woman I am
that I won't do him like he's been done
he'll he'll change and I realiz that
you're the first woman in history that
thought they could change a man I know
the first one no I here's the thing I if
he was my buddy I would have said I
don't I don't think that's wise but I
don't get a vote he didn't call me and
ask me so in that regard ask anybody he
can do whatever he wants you're the one
that chose to stay yeah his family
thinks he's crazy well it doesn't matter
what they think it matters what you
accept you've outsourced I'm still here
okay then here's what I'm gonna ask you
to do make make do make peace with it
move on because you moving into him in
into his
house and not marrying him and basically
becoming another one of his children by
the way because he's going to continue
to tell you what to do but you're going
to move into his house if you bring with
you these choices that you made to be
alone at Christmas and at Thanksgiving
and you bring with you your anger at him
for not letting you meet his kids for
six years you're choosing to poison this
part of your
life right he sounds like he was pretty
damn upfront with you he was he was and
you chose to stay so I'm going to ask
ask you to
either uh put your anger on the table
and say no more or to make peace with it
yeah say I chose this I'm gonna move on
I have done that I did say when you know
I move in I'm not going to be I'm not a
living girlfriend I'm wife material and
if you don't want to you know no you're
GNA be you're gonna be playing house
you'll be playing
house he he has a
year yeah Mary I when do you move
in
May you move in this may so he has until
May of
yes I will give you 10 products from the
ramsy solution store if you're married
by May of 26 of
25 okay I call I'll be sure I call you
back oh dude you sent an email in you
sent us a a copy of your wedding photos
I will I'll send you a link you can buy
get whatever you want out of here here's
why yeah why in the world would he marry
you I know right like he's already got
the whole Farm the cows the chickens the
Ducks I don't think you're a cow or a
chicken or a duck but I think you're
pretty awesome lady but he has no why
why in the world would he complicate his
life like that yeah for six years you
you just put up with anything he says
however he says it I know I know
I kind of don't really have I mean I
have a lot I could say but it's right it
sounds it sounds not great right yeah
yeah so here's the deal um now if he was
my friend and he called me I would have
told him to do something different he
didn't cool he did he said was gonna say
and to his credit he called it on day
one this is the way this is going to be
mhm and so you made some challenging
decisions that left you isolated and
alone and you thought you could change
him and you thought once Here's the the
the the biggest CH the biggest um miss
that you had here was you thought this
was about
you and somebody along the lines in your
life told you that
you weren't worth very
much yeah I grew up in foster care okay
and you were going to prove it to
him yeah and what you have to realize
here is that you were left in Foster
care not because of anything you
did yeah it was what was going on in
your parents
life yeah I just thought that it was me
like am I not a good enough parent to my
own children that you don't want your
children around me it was never about
you it was about
him and that's both should be both
freeing and kind of a
bummer because if you're going to marry
somebody they're telling you my life is
now all about you and you're telling
them that their life is all about you
that's what we're doing when we get
married well he say he's going
to and hey you know what he's been a man
of his word so far for the last half
decade so that's true I mean he may he
may he may invite you in on on May first
and y'all are married June 10th and I'm
out 10 products here at at the store
maybe that's the case
um this is just a it's a bigger
conversation here's the conversation a
you can't change people B people make
choices because they want to make
choices period
period and
finally man if somebody's choosing to
hide parts of their life from you it's
very hard to have a romantic
relationship that has any
value other than this than you're
underwater and you're both just taking
gulps of air out of one um scuba diving
tank
when somebody in a marriage is or or in
a long relationship y'all been playing
married for a long time when somebody
when you in a relationship and
somebody's hiding things whether it's an
addiction whether it's pornography
whether it's an affair whether it's you
can't see my kids you I w't even call
you on Christmas Day because I'm with
them so we've been together four years I
don't care you do not exist on this day
I'll call you
later um all you're doing is just
trading gulps of
air you're not both sitting on the beach
you're both underwater barely
surviving here's my recommendation Mary
as you head into this new season by the
way I don't think you should move in I
think you should get married
first and uh that's just me um you don't
need a practice run you'all been
together six years you kind of know what
you got sounds like he's a man of his
word the concrete um I would make a a
very firm list here's my boundaries
here's what I will accept in no longer
except period end of story and then you
got to come up with your or what
statement if this doesn't change then
what then I'm out then I'm just going to
take it that's fine whatever your or
what statement is um you need to come up
with it and be firm with it before you
move in otherwise you're just going to
subject yourself to this
indefinitely to answer your original
question nope never heard of this before
this one's a new one even for
me I love this
show